okay let's talk about John Kelly a
little bit now that Trump's chief of
staff John Kelly is leaving the White
House he's starting to I guess tell the
truth about stuff to the extent that we
think we can believe him now and it's
exposing that he was telling a lot of
lies
when he was actually Donald Trump's
chief of staff at the White House and
the truth is that the White House is in
chaos and it's as bad or even worse than
we all think John Kelly was interviewed
by the Los Angeles Times in a sort of
exit interview that's what it's being
called and hilariously he says that his
time at the White House can better be
measured not by what Trump did while
Kelly was there but rather by what Trump
did not do in other words Kelly is
saying the best things I did as chief of
staff were convincing Donald Trump not
to do certain things and among that list
john kelly says that he convinced trump
not to pull US troops out of south korea
merely because north korean leader kim
jong-un said he was going to do all this
great stuff that obviously he wasn't
going to do and he hasn't actually done
kelly says it was him who told trump
don't pull all the troops out of south
korea yet kelly reportedly prevented
trump from pulling troops out of Syria
and Afghanistan of course from
immediately doing that upon news of
Kelly's departure from Syria pulling
half of the troops from Afghanistan as
we will talk about with Abdullah Sharif
in the interview segment today but the
most important element of this interview
that John Kelly gave the LA Times is
that Kelly admitted that the White House
is in absolute and total chaos he
explained for example that the
implementation of the travel ban was a
total mess he admitted that they just
tried to get it out as soon as possible
and that he himself Trump's chief of
staff John Kelly himself was caught off
guard by the announcement he had no idea
that it was coming when it did Kelley
admitted that the family separation
policy at the border was a poorly
organized fiasco but most importantly he
admitted to lying although not exactly
in those words and I'll explain
john kelly once told CNN's Wolf Blitzer
that the Department of Homeland Security
started looking at the child separation
policy in March of 2017
okay Jeff Sessions eventually announced
the implementation of the policy in
April of 2018 March 17 April 18 that's
thirteen months okay
in his exit interview Kelly admits that
he was surprised by that policy being
implemented how is it that a policy that
was in the works for thirteen months
surprised Kelly in April of 2018
something is not right and the
conclusion is that the White House is an
absolute utter total mess and for those
wondering if John Kelly was the
anonymous author of that New York Times
op-ed which was critical of Trump and
written by somebody inside the
administration we didn't get that answer
we did not find that out based on this
exit interview I want to make the
following point here Pat when it comes
to John Kelly when it comes to Sean
Spicer whoever we're talking about who
has left the Trump administration I'm
against allowing their reputations to be
so easily rehabilitated once they resign
Trump's first press secretary Sean
Spicer was a merchant of some of the
most vile disinformation at the
direction of Donald Trump it's not cute
and funny
now that Sean Spicer has resigned go
through the full list of them they
willingly worked for Trump and lied and
participated in the smear campaigns and
the peddling of lies in the attacks on
media they shouldn't get their public PR
perception rehabilitated Pat because
eventually they quit
yeah the types of things that Sean
Spicer was doing and Omarosa was doing I
think they were just beautiful thick at
the time and so sycophantic that people
were sick of them at the time but then
eventually you start to grow some pity
for them and once they leave the office
you tend to
want to share some sympathy for them I
think that's what happened in those
cases and all signs point to it
happening to John Kelly too I'm sure
he'll be able to go out there write a
book exposing what's going on in the
Trump administration and he will be
revered by some these are participants
in what is taking place they are not
bystanders and you know we've talked
about this in the context of George W
Bush compared to Trump Bush seems to
have basic understandings of how
politics works basic decorum maintaining
relationships with allies but it's
really important to remember that George
W Bush was an absolutely disastrous
president who made horrible decisions
that led to countless deaths optional
decisions went after the wrong country
for the 9/11 attacks presented along
with : Powell and others a case based on
totally bogus intelligence for why we
should go to Iraq so yeah he's not as
whacked as president Trump and he
wouldn't embarrass the world the United
States on the world stage to the degree
that Donald Trump has but he was still a
disaster and in the same way Spicer was
part of it John Kelly
scaramouche II whoever right they may be
funny now that they're out we may see
them as less offensive or threatening
characters now that they've parted ways
with the Trump administration but they
should not be allowed to have this full
rehabilitation of their public persona
just because they have ultimately
decided eventually decided in some cases
after years of working for this guy that
they're not going to participate any
more if you disagree with me if you
think they should have their public
image rehabilitated so easily let me
know why I'm open to having my mind
changed make sure you follow me on
Instagram I posted some wacky wacky hate
mail that we received over the New Year
holiday to my Instagram today David
Pakman on Instagram also follow the
david pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show lots of good stuff there
quick break back after this with
Abdullah Sharif one of today's sponsor
is privacy dot-com / Pakman this is a
free service that I've actually been
using myself for a while now and I love
it you just take a few seconds to link
your debit card or bank account to
privacy coms mobile app or browser
extension for Firefox and Chrome and
what that does is allow you to instantly
create virtual credit cards that are
linked to your bank account so that
you're not actually putting your real
debit card number on the Internet and
you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets five dollars towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link below